all right so today we're finishing up to
do utilitarians and last time we
introduced this distinction between a
qualitative and middle is trying to
improve on phones philosophy right yeah
the same thing is going to happen with
the material that we're looking at today
most of them I've asked them doing the
rules as opposed to attorneys yeah this
is a distinction I think you guys can
wrap your head around or easily filter
Ian's perspective would be okay if you
consider that in isolation
just as this kind of so the gameshow
example that we do sometimes where we
pick one of you put you in a game show
where we do you know terrible things to
you embarrassing things that you have
recovering from not so much physically
but mentally and we all enjoy it all
right so from up from utilitarian
perspective provided that the pleasure
that we all gift and watching you and
I'll do whatever Beatles shows so once
we get more pleasure than the thin your
pain it's okay there's a benefit that's
not only okay we want it back but if you
think about it in terms of let's say we
made that a general practice or a rule
in society how that can you think that
would lead to a better society overall
for what some of those things start to
make you feel bad give you a sense
that's
maybe the discussable if that's the case
then it would have sort of collateral
damage you might say there would be some
pain beyond just what's in the situation
to society shouldn't you take a lot to
your own hands if you're thinking about
this from utilitarian perspective I
think there's a good argument at least
if you're considering that's for the
case sure what if we made that a general
practice it's good that you got yeah but
then there's a reason why vigilantes are
illegal because we have a court system
where we can figure out whether it was
really not that person we did it and if
he part many people who haven't done it
then I guess the whole population
feel safe at that point yeah well you
know you could look at historical
studies and you could say what happens
in societies where people start in
general taking the law into their own
hands and say forming militias or things
like that well look at Somalia look at
some other that we call failed States
those are sort of an extreme example but
you know it's worth thinking about this
the urban gangs that we have many of
them started out as protective
associations neighborhood you know
building solutions and that maze were
morphed over time there's a tendency for
these sort of things to become corrosive
and that's what rule utilitarianism
takes into account so there's some
things that from a act perspective would
be okay that from a rural perspective
are not going to get there and that's
mostly what we're going to talk about
today duties and justice before we do
that I wanted one is I want to bring up
this quote here because this is kind of
a good one to sort of Center everything
around and then we're going to talk
about motivation and how we make moral
decisions so this is something Martin
Luther King said and I don't know if all
of you seen this quote before in one
form or another this is a great quote
for what we're looking at today it says
it may be true that the law cannot make
a man love me but it can keep them from
lynching so there's there's some things
that the law can or watch it keeping
people from lynching other people
the law can't make a person love another
person as a lawyer recently said today
was we were talking about the sort of
thing you cannot legislate personality a
judge cannot say to somebody you have to
you have to love this other person you
have to even like facilities and not
only cannot get judge is not do that can
your teachers make you like other people
they might persuade you to but they
can't make it by dividing the person I
say okay now you really get to know like
all the people here matter of fact do
you feel a little you feel that's a
little weird to try to make you like
other people be kind to them but don't
kill each other I can tell you that you
can tell me that we have rights involved
their rights and duties so this is keep
this in mind as we're going through this
this distinction between two different
kinds of good act because it's good not
too much people it's bad too much people
it's good too long people to us it's
better it's a lot of people than to not
go for me until appearing in respect to
behave
to feel the sense of attachment those
are good things but there's some things
that can be matters of justice and
others which are not matters of justice
so that said now let's think about what
he talks about in terms of human
motivation
in your experience when you have had in
the past to decide cases right and wrong
and you could have missed uses where
they were say two different right things
it seemed like there were two right
things to do in the situation but they
weren't equally compatible like you know
the example that circuit should is this
young man you don't walk in during the
resistance and fight the Nazi occupation
that would be a right thing to do to
serve you know not only ones country but
to get these occupiers out but if you
also want to stay want to take care of
his aging mother with worry an awful lot
of she knew that ever somewhere out
there facing danger there are two right
things to do and sometimes difficult to
decide between these other cases are
where there's somebody's going to get
hurt no matter what there's it's very
difficult to find the right thing and
the sense that you know it satisfies
every requirement and we have to choose
sometimes between two or three people's
we have to figure out which is the
lesser of the two evils because our
familiar with cases like that 200
friends
give to irreconcilable conflict with
each other and become enemies you don't
have a third option of you know making
them get back together do you a choose
this friend because this friend
see try to play you know half and half d
extricate yourself from the situation
altogether none of those are really
going to be done but you could talk
about wrong and then sometimes there's
situations where you know what the right
thing to do and you know what the wrong
thing to do is but unfortunately you're
attempted by the wrong thing and you are
motivated by the right and it's a
question of whether you're going to
resist that temptation or or you know
follow
these kind of situations probably face a
situation like that every time that you
have to decide to do homework sort of
readings or things like that or to go
visit somebody who you really want to
visit but you watch your other state
home yeah these are common things and
how do you normally decide distance do
you go through a process in your mind
you may do this for some things where
you draw can teach art and our pros and
cons and you list them on each side
maybe don't drive and you tally it up in
your mind are you talking over with
somebody how many of you ever do that
how many of you would say that you do
that most of the time very few any of
you ever go through now that you know we
went through a totalitarian calculation
how many of you started making that part
of your your way of approaching moral
problems not only do you draw like a
teacher you actually give numbers to
these things and then you've done that
for each person and you put all the
numbers together and figure it out that
way does anybody ever do that I've never
done that my wife we use things kind of
we make arguments with each other we say
well look this is gonna benefit most of
the group and it could be things as
trivial as you get a bunch of people
together and you
get a pizza okay who wants one out the
pizzas it's always somebody who doesn't
like sausage doesn't like that bro what
do you tell them and you can pick it up
because the rest of us like this and
we're gonna go with what the group as a
whole is going to be happy you know did
you ever frame that in terms of you know
Jeremy Bentham and John Stuart Mill said
we should always maximize utility that
is we should always bring about the
action that will maximize pleasure
minimize pain for all those concern your
friends would look at you like you're
crazy right or maybe we don't invoke
this if we're gonna be true you're gonna
try to all be utilitarian we should
actually use it as though we should be
making recourse to this we should make
that a habit of the way in which we
decide this how do we actually decide
things so you guys have been through a
lot of different moral problematic
situations how do you cited it - I feel
like after we kind of develop a pattern
and your decision-making
okay so patterns habits little uses a
great term
what else give er give er again animals
animals yeah wait a lot of words for
this impulse sometimes they say just
like intermission the lining of their
guts give it guts gut feeling that
something you should this is the right
thing to do you can't quite explain us
somebody but you know it's the right
thing to do you know this is the wrong
thing to do
can't quite articulate why well anything
else that pops up sometimes willing to
bet most if not all of you some rules
not necessarily you know systematically
put together and thought out some of the
rules
or maybe even sayings
that's right heading towards it could be
in some cases and in other cases they're
just thrown together this this whole
mishmash that milk comes of association
recalls customary in reality and that's
a good question
think about the way in which you learn
the rules that have probably been
something regarded to your mind that had
become part of your more wife when you
were a little kid your parents rewarded
you and punish you and they praised you
and they they criticized you know your
parents didn't do that something wrong
but everybody else did it to your
teachers did it your peers did it
teachers probably screw up their to your
coaches didn't everything everybody did
it around we're constantly influencing
each other morally but we do some uh
very informal less principled more sort
of on the fly ways so you did something
wrong you hit your brother your sister
and your parents are punished you don't
hit people and then you said something
like but I was mad at them but they did
this they said doesn't matter you still
don't you were learning it in the sense
of a general moral principle with a New
Yorker
why don't we hit people and they said
well that's that question see the
greatest happiness principle understood
this way they didn't write this wouldn't
they often say things like because I
said stuff or that's just the way it is
or shut up
right and that's the live most of us
learning around that's why I'm in
reality and there were some things too
where you yourself probably did some
thinking about it you know this isn't
fair that you know things should go this
way so that that entries into it as well
your own reflections I think but a lot
of these rules are sayings you don't
think about when you - ask your mom or
dad if they were in certain kind of
households that they have quoted the
Bible to you honor thy mother and my
father for that come from ten
commandments God wants you to do this
you know they said well what does it
really have you probably got some
discussion about it at some point if
that came up but it probably wasn't one
in terms of general principles it was
probably a lot of things thrown in
together and another thing that comes up
as well
do you like this person don't be like
this person and we get some of those
from our parents why can't you be more
like your brother more like you don't be
like your screw up uncle look at those
are the best he's made of his life those
are a lot of pretty months people get on
TV who you think's got kind of got the
life together you model yourself after
them hopefully those that have got their
life pretty well screwed up you don't
say
that all this gets kind of thrown
together and by the time you're your age
you've lived through a ton of this stuff
and you have in fact form patterns or
habits or associations and those feel
like the way things ought to be
you may you know change and reconsider
it over time you may you may look at
yourself at certain points I know I did
it myself and say wow I'm a jerk I need
to quit acting this way people don't
like this you know putting people that I
like or alienating people or this is not
working for me
or I don't even like this myself you
know that didn't happen from time to
time but for the most part we're kind of
so you know sailing along and reacting
to situations and we're not you know
relying on some sort of general
principle we're relying on feeling we
come up with some of you know
explanations but a lot of times they're
just kind of trolling together on the
fly
and your parents did this and their
grandparents did this unless your
parents were like you know moral
philosophers or something theologians
which is pretty you know I mean my dad
was was a tax attorney he didn't even do
stuff like that you just say it's just
the way it is
common sense says that's the way the
world works
so you're gonna feel that this makes a
lot more sense intuitively than this
that will go for any system of ethics in
up to this point when you were reading
Plato and about virtue ethics you said
this I don't really feel this call of
justice
you know these virtues well that's
because it's moral theory you're not
used to thinking in terms in the rest of
your practical life on moral theory that
can help you out a lot but you have to
actually like choose to make it part of
part of balance part of your to do
associations and so what middle of sands
if utilitarianism was actually doing the
work as a way of structuring things what
you would have to do is change the way
people are educated about matters
teaching wait earlier not just in sort
of a naive way you know a little Johnny
little Susie you're you're faced with
this problem of how to divide up the
cake should you divide it up you know
evenly or give your friends bigger
pieces
well how does everybody as a whole gonna
feel if you if you play favorites that's
sort of doing a totalitarianism you know
for kids in the classroom with a very
practical application that would fit the
greatest happiness principle but you're
not actually working it out are you you
know getting them to see
we should always use that we're ordering
pizza
what car need to find one what movie to
watch or things like that but you could
do that couldn't you we could in fact
have you know we couldn't have people as
attached to this as they are this I
think you got some folks that have maybe
some movies maybe if some of you even
think of movies and then I do like when
you're in high school or middle school
had to read Walden 2 or great food world
I forget the wallet to is by but
breaking the rules by Huxley those would
be utilitarian Wars where they're
actually trying to carry out an
education which gets people to associate
their pleasure their desires with the
pleasures of a whole community so I
think you can see some things like that
they don't know they don't necessarily
have to be a bad sort
but I can't think of any ham things that
do motivate us that we need to look at
challenges
yeah there are some people who get
beyond just customary morality and there
are what is the virtue ethics virtues
time Dan ecology thinks that doing your
duties
yeah community I don't know how to put
that what does utility also
somebody's editor and
Reno's utilitarianism is a is a human
right yeah utilitarianism says that this
want to be Vienna and everything
everything it should be a means
everything else is good insofar as it
ultimately leads to pleasure and pain
and whose pleasure in the majority or
the balance of people overall but now
we're talking about the individual how
do you motivate the individual because
some individuals seem to be more
motivated by duty than pleasure pain
they'll actually sacrifice some pleasure
and undergo some pain themselves to do
their duty as a matter of fact they'll
say hey I don't care what the with the
consequences are I didn't do the right
thing so even if it have good
consequences I still feel bad or they'll
say hey I still feel good even though
things turned out badly is I chose the
right thing that's the right thing to do
always ought to do the right thing what
the consequences are other people are
motivated by wanting to be a certain
kind of person panics certain character
traits you know being this sort of
person it might be might be identify
this with social roles like I said being
a good cop that might not just be a
matter of doing
without any doubt that's a very
interesting question does a big Russian
so I can't give one full answer to it
I consider historically we have people
who at least from what we can tell kid
what they saw as being the right thing
even though they put them and oftentimes
people that they care about a great risk
or
Wow they were they were really tough to
do maybe I couldn't have different
meteors so yeah I think there's cases
where one could think the main thing
especially people like we're discussing
absolutely yeah the pain of not
following your values it's bigger yes
then the pain you would have received by
following yeah and you're getting two
mil is gonna make his argument so this
is this is an N that's acknowledged for
just about everybody but there could be
other ends mill says well they're not
really other ends as a matter of fact if
you look at why somebody let's take
another one will take well if I give you
$5.00
okay let's say you can actually do a
little bit with like go to Starbucks and
get yourself a latte when they don't get
too many muscles I give this to you in a
car like you guys have student mailboxes
right so I send this to you in a car you
get this you feel good and the good
feeling that comes with this this has no
minutes it's not even like particularly
aesthetically attractive other people's
except that ours feels better to us
because we can actually use it to buy
things that we like and you have put
together over the course of your
lifetime and lots of experience handing
this to somebody getting something in
return if you like right having so many
of these in the wallet and knowing that
you can go and get some things at you
you're like yeah the cash machine and
seeing these come rolling out you have
sort of you know good associations and
why because you desire this happen but
does some people become so fixated on
the money itself that they all seem to
lose sight of the pleasures that can
provide them yeah people scrimp and save
and I have installs all sorts of
pleasures why did I do that well because
they get a greater pleasure out of
having with money than the rest of us
like spending the money right but it's
no pleasure in pain and that pleasure
came about through a process of
Association
the same thing can work for duty we need
a kid you do your news yeah if you're
doing your duties whatever they're
perceived to be you in general get
plungers or you're at least not getting
pings you know maybe maybe your parents
more the place you were not punish you
that reward you know sort of sort or
maybe they were of the opposite you know
we're gonna reward you a lot or reward
you less or not at all but why did you
start doing duties in the first place
did you do because you thought they were
great in and of themselves probably you
didn't because they left a good outcomes
like your chores how many insurance
markets why did you do those chores does
he have to what would happen was the
whole camp we had something that went
beyond time publishing school yeah that
was worse than spankings I had rather
take a spanking yeah instead of this
hard stool faced the wall for 15 minutes
which sounds pretty easy right except
that if you asked how long you were into
it the 15 minute starting now when
you're you know 6 7 8 9 10 15 minutes
seems like an eternity doesn't never
vary
yeah I mean we could end up being in
that stool for two hours because it was
so hard to resist the temptation to ask
what is it over yeah well that made an
impression on me
we probably have things I made an
impression side you they have like right
I'm looking that all of you did and
that's you know that's pain what kind of
what kind of pleasures what's that
cookies yeah oh those are good pleasures
you got a chance to do stuff you like
rather than spending time being punished
oh it opened up opportunities for other
things yeah yeah that's that's true
we're getting for the idea or word maybe
you got to go to the show right play
time you got to go for your friends
house we could like go through all those
really important prayers that your
parents praised you for doing the right
thing you know if they saw you being
fair with other kids or the teachers or
whoever and I said that's a really good
thing for you to do you're a good kid
you felt that you liked them wrong with
you you didn't like they call them the
kid became the associate duty itself
with the pleasure in pain the duty was
originally just a means to them but
eventually you forget that the Duty
starts to take down
it's all feel the kind of pleasure doing
your duty and you feel like a pain you
don't do your right and it starts to
look like this is the motivating end for
you but really what's still going on is
it's still all about Fletcher and pain
but now there's a pleasure and pain
that's come with doing it's something
that's the reason why you feel that way
in your heartbeat in the fabric of your
your person about duties so if you
discover they get a new duty you
transfer that feeling over to that it's
not just you know you know the set of
chores now your students right you have
you have different duties now when you
get out of school
imagine a lot of you eventually are
going to be married or at least you
don't have long term committed
relationships you're gonna have duties
that come with that that are gonna get a
bit different nutrients you know whole
bunch of there's a few kids other duties
are going to come with that jobs that
you're preparing for that's going to
come with that some of you know it's
they're so motivated by this sense of
duty now that when you do it you feel
feel good the more that you do that the
more you're going to feel if you're
motivated by duty and you fail to do it
you feel bad and each time that you feel
that feeling and you tell yourself
that's the way that it ought to be your
reinforcement same thing for virtues for
character traits for thinking about the
kind of person you you want to be for
modeling yourself a dresser
when you work yet you are rewarded
punished praise blamed for when you got
pleasure and pain for exhibiting certain
character traits you are greedy that
your parents call you on them
don't be so greedy you probably don't
realize don't be greedy too because
other kids didn't like it when you were
greedy you took more than your fair
share and you probably also realized
that that wasn't a good character trait
you didn't like it when the other kids
yet to write if you're nice to people
people treat you next sir you're mean to
people they don't like you there's
certain character traits so I end up
justice courage you stand up but when
you believe in at the right time to the
right degree I like crazy beating people
up over at all the time but you know
actually like standing up in the face of
adversity to people respect up gentlemen
do they respect cowards not much
what virtues you have or what virtues
you aspire to what virtues you see as
good things as good character traits is
a manner from permille pleasure deep
down inside and you only think that this
is a necessary end for you because
you've forgotten this whole process
where it was just a means and now it's
taking on the role of them but why is it
an ending because it brings me pleasure
to have or to exhibit or to think of
yourself having these characteristics
and it brings you pain to think that you
don't have so you know feeling feeling
that you would like to do the wrong
thing because you
not yet entirely honest or just or
courageous that makes you feel bad why
does it make you feel bad
well because Mel says this whole process
of association so this is a nice way to
try to sweep everything all into
utilitarianism I don't know you can
think about whether you buy it I see
some some problems with this but I think
this is something we should model over a
bit where these are some of the key
things we're going to look at through
the rest of the semester duty virtue but
are these you know which of these should
phenomena which of these should be yeah
so basically mill kindly puts this down
for like the most basic form of an
animal kind of deal to this like oh that
if you think about it like you were
talking about the monkey that you
mentioned why could it make monkeys
virtuous pretty much I mean if I portray
this characteristic look all the other
monkey's like me yeah fine if I do this
all the other monkey's like me if I
follow this Duty even though I don't
like it right now it's gonna bring me
pleasure later on you know I mean so
like this same thing like the monkey
that didn't go to grab the bananas
yeah because Duty required and not to
otherwise all the monkeys would turn on
him because the other monkeys would be
hurt kind of deal I don't you know I
don't think they think of it to that
extent but the way Miller explains it
it's kind of like all right the thought
process is kind of out of the head net
like we don't even think about it
anymore and we just learned it when
we're young and that's it well no we
would still lose something about it we
would still use principles but we have
scientist right you know I mean talks
for example we're gonna see this next
week about doing duty you can do duty
for the sake of some reward or
punishment or you can do what the duty
requires because you recognize that
that's the right thing to do I'm not
sure if this was this embarrassing you
know looking at I don't know whether
whether it could be set to do and
recognize duties for the sake of Duty
itself I don't know let me shift topics
so if we have duties things that we
should do that we feel like we should do
that we think other people want to do we
recognize as good things to do from
utilitarian perspective milk brings up a
distinction and this is one that Conte
is also going to use meritorious
students if you say that something is
too strict due to you're saying that
somebody really has to do it or they're
doing the wrong thing there's something
seriously wrong a meritorious or an
imperfect duty is something that that's
good for them to do it's better than not
doing it but it's not absolutely not
okay he says perfect your strict duties
would be these things like depriving a
person with possession
or breaking a promise or agreement
summer or treating a person worse than
they deserve or worse than other people
have no greater claims plank fingers
being corrupt being unfair that's right
what are some imperfect duties being
kind of people this goes again to that
Martin Luther King all right the law can
tell you that you can't kill other
people that you can't use violence
against them but the law can't make you
look okay it's matter of fact the mere
fact that you can't use violence it seem
like you know when you want you might
make you hate us
lovely people would be an example of an
imperfect duty if you're with your
spouse
you've made a marital commitment you're
not supposed to cheat on them right
I don't even have everyone agrees that
more or less unless you have one of
these things they call open marriage you
can debate about what's the apparent or
not in general I think if you're married
to somebody you're not supposed to be
having sex with other people right
that's a pretty strict dude it would be
good if you love your spouse it would be
good if you don't cheat on your spouse
because you love them but that's not
actually required in ordinary kiss now
there are plenty of marriages you think
of people are people there would be
better thing I should love their spouse
but they don't then we don't say well
the law should you know do something
about this society should come down hard
on them because you might go up to them
and say hey you know you're married to a
great person you probably should
actually appreciate that saying you have
an imperfect duty that's one way to
think about this is corresponding
or duties all right if I have a right
not to be lied to by you you have a duty
not to lie to me if I have a right if I
came for a certain service for you you
know to that service then you have a
duty to provide me with that service if
I have people with meritorious duties
there isn't a corresponding right you
see the difference I don't have a right
to to expect that you lock me like being
care about me talk to me in a nice way
may that sort of stuff any of you think
that I have a right to them yeah I think
that's a good way to put it when it
comes to meritorious duties in good
society we we have an expectation of
that if you were the people that you
know are jerks you don't expect them
they can fulfill all their perfect
duties and then they say all right I
don't have to do screw everybody else
and you know we said well it would be
better if you behave in a different way
you actually cared about people it's not
just enough just to obey the law or to
you know
violate people's rights you should
actually be a good person in other words
you know like helping the other person
when you don't have to if you have to
help them they have a right for you to
help them like if you are their
caregiver or you know even more if you
contracted to help a person for a
certain amount of money they have a
right to expect that does the old lady
you know
session have a right to expect you to
help across the street no you have a
duty but it's not a perfect or
restrictive it's an imperfect it would
be better for you because you did not
it would produces greater happiness
overall but you don't have to do that as
a matter of fact you could say good luck
lady
lights gonna change quick and really
fast and you would be a jerk to do so
you wouldn't be violating any strict
duties and doings we trekked out Rogers
going across that was terrific you
politely to strict duty with them
tonight inflict harm on ya so can
perfect duties we think often though
they're not the ones that want to be
enforced by the legal system or by
society they're things that like mill
says we which people should do we like
or hire them for doing prehaps just like
our despise them for not doing but admit
they're not bound in yeah someone heat
is really big Oh once it's made into a
law now there's a dude yeah sometimes
well there's a sort of a quickie in to
do this a little longer answer the
longer answer involves things like
talking about mills other works where he
thinks that we have like moral progress
we get better better than that over time
so he's willing to say that legal
systems come to a better a better
understanding which actually are it's a
good question because if you think about
like the story of the Good Samaritan
it's portrayed as this story of a person
who you know completely gratuitous thing
I mean it's America at that time in a
Jew they did not mix they couldn't
same table they hated each other and
this guy treats an enemy of his people
in a loving manner actually leaves some
money and says take care of this guy I'm
gonna come back this is some game the
Good Samaritan was you got it all from
knowing what those are those are the
laws and some states at the car accident
what would have a law like that truly
where you carry society that's one
question not the existence that it
already uses yeah what we have placement
even though we don't expect rate of
people that's been questioning me yeah
maybe that would be the case
I know mill was more focused on changing
things in his fall in society and in his
own time they were less far along my
club captive practicin than we are today
let me let me sort of table those those
note those as good questions in there
because I didn't want to get through the
rest of this so one way to think about
perfect and introduce in terms of Rights
another way to think about it is in
terms of the greatest happiness
principle these are the ones that if
they're not not enforced this is reason
why dolphins we feel that they ought to
be enforced it produces greater
collateral damage throughout the society
says they're more vital than direct
concern to society than imperfect duties
because there is necessity more vital to
human well-being these the legal system
he talks about imperfect duties because
being the province of Education
independence so you know we need to
teach kids things like you ought to be
nice to each other we don't
let's focus now on these
another way to think about it so one way
the thing about these is if they're not
enforced so if you were to we would have
a society in which in order to get
justice you have to bribe officials
which is the case in some places and
there are some countries where the
action just to do business you have to
factor in the cost of bribes in business
now why is that why is it a problem from
a injustice or rights perspective well
if I have to do that first of all that's
violating my right to be treated fairly
according to the system but think about
this if I can bribe a judge or an
official in my case and you're somehow
involved in that case it is a competitor
I've not only just you know doesn't make
for me expert you over so if we deserve
to be treated fairly if it's a legal
case deserves to be heard on its merits
not just who happens to pay the judge
more and I happen to be rich and we have
to be poor you're not going to have your
rights respond to you have a right to
equal treatment
you know let's say equal treatment for
equal cases what if then were to become
a pattern in society as it is in
society's will that lead to overall bad
effects
yeah people would trust each other loss
whenever things were decided there would
be this feeling that it was really
decided it was more based on who had the
money if we let people decide of the
jury system our jury system is far from
perfect we let people decide of the jury
system just on the basis of who they
like on the basis of race religion
gender how would people look at the jury
system they'd be happier with it so if
the Rockets are respected then that
leads to a worse outcome overall this
takes secured by the way of things like
the game show thing if we already have a
society which we could serve them let's
simply pluck people off the street so
today it's you and we're you know this
is part of our society not like in
certain movies you know so you're going
to be put into this game show situation
where yeah so we do that right and now
you're a contestant we watch we all
enjoy this we're into this show you get
a lot of pleasure out of that we're
happy it's not obvious to you by the way
so we even get more pleasure you're
going to experience a lot of pain
so we would find ways to kill each other
gruesome horrible ways let's definitely
violating a whole bunch of Rights isn't
it I mean she was right not to be
plucked up off the street and thrown
into some situation I think we call that
kidnapping
or wrongful abduction she has a right
not to be forced to fight to the death
with other people not to be treated as
being less than humans on your space
right what kind of society would that
lead to over all know you know remember
from a utilitarian perspective we'd say
no that's ok
greater pleasure less pain what kind of
society with that penis if it's the
thought of that bothers does the thought
of their father anything if that bothers
you that think of that bother should be
taken into account that would actually
lower the amount of pleasure I think if
we it's one thing to to imagine this and
it's another thing to see something like
this in place if you were in a society
like that I'm willing to bet that most
if not all of you would feel some two
sets of moral repugnance towards this
life this makes us worse as there's
something wrong with our society we do
this if that's the case then you would
lead to less even though in the
individual cases it's more
expensive one person it will lead to
more pain overall
I was just going to say the Romans
called themselves up it's pretty ethical
people I guess but yet they had the
fights like in the Colosseum and they
would put an equal there against their
own pretty low yeah I mean it's kind of
like unfortunately a trend in our
societies that we act in such a manner
that the Romans actually thought of
themselves as a whole as being superior
to Roman society began collapsing from a
bit but you know it didn't didn't fall
apart just because the Germans came in
it fell apart from the inside looks
let's move on so another way of thinking
about it I think mill doesn't talk about
here but you could frame it a million
contacts being private these involved
pins that are qualitatively words that
are more degrading that stabilize things
for the familiar this is why I for
example I mean milk and you know we have
this thing with quantitative and
qualitative pleasures the qualitative
pleasures to be preferred over positive
and higher pleasures to be preferred
over any amount of the qualitative with
lowered pleasure it works is hanging
with pins there's some pains in there
that are worse that somebody who's
experienced both of these would say I
will put up with any amount to this
lesser amount of pain like a whole bunch
of two things provided I don't have to
go through this oh yeah
there's some things that are so
degrading so so painful that I think
some people would do that perhaps one
way to think about this is when you
violate somebody's rights in this sense
here sojust mill says these ought to be
enforced what does it ultimately go back
to this leads to better consequences for
the society this is what movies
militarism is about so the two latarian
Ang Mo is not going to violate rights or
justice just in terms of expedience you
doesn't leave an escape - and there
could be cases where the payoff for
honoring a certain right might be so bad
that you could overturn in that case he
talks about says particular cases may
occur in which some other social duty is
so important as to overrule any one of
the general Maxim's of justice thus to
save a life it may not only be allowable
but duty
so not only permissible but the duty to
steal or to take my force the necessary
food or medicine you know if you're if
you're in a really bad unjust situation
that may be what's required to kidnap
and compel to officiate the only
qualified medical practitioner but he
says in such cases what is just an
ordinary cases is by reason of the other
principle not just the particular case
heavy case like this is going to involve
some other rights being so it's not a
matter of just
every once in a while you violate these
rules you'd have to have a good reason
but there'd have to be sort of laying
off rights against each other
let's think of a couple of examples
one of the ones that I was thinking
about has to do with marriage and Boris
and child-rearing and stuff like that
yeah I'm gonna tell you about a
particularly horrific case that I heard
about recently it's for my home state
I think it's I'm not gonna going to do
the details about it you can find the
details out there pretty soon there was
a girl who was four years how in her
houses basement she lived through I
remember my father father remarried so
just stepmother and she had a brother
so four people a family when they
brought her out she waited on the 7
pounds which is I think around 14 she
was starved she was made to stay in the
basement notes one of the facilities and
washing in cold water and sink everyday
was beaten raped
with brought out of the was brought out
of the basement sometimes just if you
put in the yard to say cinder blocks
around they're totally nonsensical tasks
her mother or step mother and father way
you know like over 200 pounds each and
she would hear them prepare meals
upstairs rather her down watching TV and
shooting to trying to basically this is
this cabin you know this way and some
whatever television have time to feed
her so she starved she probably would
have died it took a lot of time for the
social service agencies to actually be
involved and they finally did that
now imagine just how horrific her life
was those people who are doing they they
got a lot of pleasure they were sadists
so pleasure that they were getting
newest a illegitimate but still from
utilitarian perspective the pleasures
pleasures and there's three of them only
wanted her so that you might say well
you know this from you till from a
certain utilitarian perspective this
might actually make sense but if you
feel a sort of repugnance towards that
do you when you hear about these these
cases does it make you feel kind of sick
and so I read the Marshall makes me
the violation of Rights that the sort of
degradation that's taking place is so
bad when the middle call it Obama that
you could pretty much I mean this
probably would justify vigilantism going
in and taking some sort of situation
that's an example of how things can go
drastically wrong now think of much more
trivial examples get away from uses
limit extreme cases should society to be
able to regulate how families are
structured what goes on in families I've
been in cases like that yeah not giving
your kid food medical attention or basic
sanitation that's definitely a violation
right Steve is a staple watching me
write about other things it gets a lot
trickier think about food or is it a
famous there was a case that's becoming
famous now down in North Carolina where
a girl whose mother sent a pretty good
lunch not considered balanced I guess
from the perspective of the school who
would have met rates for luncheon in my
day probably in your day too
turkey sandwich or something like that
the school said - they're doing
inspections it's not a balanced launch
but they made her buy food in the
cafeteria now what is going out in there
some of these are actually asserting
this is the right thing to do this is a
policy that we don't want to have you
know for me a toilet here in perspective
should we dictate that parents have to
provide certain level of nutrition to
the children yeah I know the full story
but I won't say because it will ruin the
purpose of this right after we discussed
it I'll tell ya what they actually serve
good job yeah I mean they definitely got
a list of you have to have so many
servants of this so I started writing
there was something that thank you
the broader the broader thing should
should should the state or Society or
some larger entity be you know making
sure that parents provide certain kinds
of food to their children
maybe not other guys they made sure they
shouldn't have lots of so think about
that from utilitarian perspective their
rights involved what kind of society it
could be that that would be a good thing
overall I mean if somebody tells if
somebody's telling you you can't you
can't crap and you can't feed them you
know empty calories that sounds like a
good thing could it lead to worse
effects overall if the state that's
coming in
are you there this was an open question
for the utilitarian method to paint this
on its merits
we're just appealing the mistake and set
certain standard I just tried it chips I
just think it's utterly falling for
somebody you walk around and do that and
that lunch right there that sounds like
a good healthy lunch to me yeah I don't
know yeah it's it's an interesting case
there's a much broader set of food
issues involved let me shift the topic
up for another example two other things
about marriage what do we think is
involved when people actually get
married are there are their rights
towards each other that come with that
whatever would you say they are strict
ruts where you know these ought to be
enforced in the past we don't have
no-fault divorce the most most states
we're not actually any reason for
divorce of somebody in the past if you
wanted to get divorce yet that's some
sort of reason and that could that could
possibly be a good reason to say hey
there's no money there they're working
but they spend all on gambling or liquor
or something like that you know either
because they're not taking care of
without providing basic
yep - to not be punished for expressing
themselves okay is that do you think
that's a right that ought to be yeah
yeah maybe
bring up domestic violence that's a good
good example we can't say there's
definitely a right not to have force
using US University sometimes we're
talking in terms of emotional abuse
maybe you could say that there ought to
be some sort of this big of emotional
abuse might actually be worse some forms
of physical use of these incidently you
could make a case with this
qualitatively worse name from the museum
perspective that rape is in some sense a
worse
okay so a lot of these are so I don't do
this don't do that
are there other things in a marriage
that ought to be the case but we
probably wouldn't want to say well do
this you're legally liable some of these
have changed over time and in the past
you committed adultery if you if you
were married and you you know around
somebody else you've been getting a lot
of trouble you can still do so a
military justice lob states have gotten
rid of those you might say there's more
right though
what if I said you're married to
somebody you have a newer right to
fidelity on their part why get married
otherwise why not just maybe it's not a
legal right anymore but I think you'd
probably still considered a moral right
do you have a right to expect that your
spouse is going to behave in loving
manner towards that be right in this
sense like a strict duty or do you think
that might be a meritorious
do you think system I mean let's suppose
that the state because the state's not
gonna come watch it you think society
like your neighbor is your family all
that we should like you know make sure
that you you love your husband or your
wife yeah well it could be society in
general yeah if we feel that some sort
of there are some people that's true
yeah they like this person's house car
yeah let me ask you another one I've
brought up the other the clouds that
seems like an interesting let's say it's
not even misdemeanors married spouses
just any sort of committed relationship
do you have a duty to reveal to your
spouse previous relationships that
you've had if you're still in some way
involved with those you're still working
with divers
I think the consequences of your
significant other finding that out and
to the extent that they'd be pissed off
finally you should just come out and say
it anyways and so if you're good
utilitarian well the idea is is going to
be so much worse if they find that
but you say that when people like
violate other people's rights then it
becomes the duty of someone else's a
check like I feel like memory and police
duties aren't don't get completed then
it's their job to check you know it's
kind of like a cycle you're exactly
right and that's that's what mill was
talking about in this session in terms
of compulsion
he doesn't talk in terms of like
military or police or we could also
extend this for corrections officers
he's talking about it in terms of if we
think that somebody has a strict duty to
respect some of these rights that they
ought to be compelled to respect those
rights
who does that in our society police
their remaining corrections officers who
else I suppose it in a lesser sense
that's what using compulsion but using
persuasion and teachers parents other
organizations you're exactly right yeah
to say that somebody has a right means
that if somebody isn't respecting it
somebody else want to be maybe a police
officer is a greater duty to make sure
that that happens so the police officer
it's not quite the same thing let's say
a business person there's a greater
violation produces greater and happiness
in society let's look at a few examples
that we could think about these terms
abortion is a great example of part of
this how to both sides of the the
abortion debate that's been going on for
now close to 30 years longer than
actually versus wait how do they often
print the frame in terms of records
don't there there's two ways in which
which the debates usually get arranged
leave religion outside of it for a
moment is the religious stuff walking so
the killing to rights were ends up
appealing to utilitarian what are the
rights that are usually thrown out there
on the table
you could look at more to me if you were
looking at this from strictly strictly
utilitarian perspective you'd also want
to use my father if he knows about it
who cares
maybe the grandparents as a societal
issue you could probably look at the
whole society some societies that you
know legalized abortion because of other
things that are going on in their
society and had now ended up with
massive gender analysis right China in
India India actually had passed a law
outlawing ultrasounds because too many
girl fetuses were being imported in that
generation I'm starting to look like
what's happening with China
but you're right you usually have
strengths in terms of plumbers rights
what are we already resolved are as a
nation
what's up the right to choose or also in
terms of reproductive boons is the state
board this views quite often these days
so right to choice Roe versus way to
actually figured it out as a right to
choose but a right to privacy that if
you look at the case that's where this
and then the the other side out of their
frame that they're they focus on online
fetus right to life right so we have
what looks like in the world alone
because you have different rights being
being contested
and if you were going to try to resolve
this individual cases where if you're
going to try to resolve this on a
societal you know basis of emotion we
have laws regulating this no one say you
have to look at in terms of riots you
have to actually determine who has
rights one of the problems with the
abortion debate is there's no general
agreement on precisely who has blood
rights that's one reason why it's so
intractable once you actually decide
that there is a right to life on the
part of penis you're pretty much going
to be on one side party if you focus
exclusively on a woman's right to choose
or a right to privacy or reproductive
rights those sorts of things and you
don't look at this you're going to be on
the side if you actually put all of them
on the table that gets a little bit
trickier doesn't know that's where we
get to situations
what if she's raped what if the child
was because he had less than ideal wife
because of genetic defects
what if she's raising the child in
poverty the people lay out these sorts
of things could this people kept from
utilitarian perspective in terms of
overall happiness and unhappiness
probably I mean there's actually a third
and option between the open season
abortion and no abortion whatsoever that
our society is not relating more
adoptions right carrying a children to
term and finding them homes
the utilitarian perspective that might
actually be the best thing pick one
which could respect the majority of the
right some question about better
outcomes let's take another one that's
perhaps a little bit more
straightforward think about our judicial
system we have this principle that it's
you're innocent until proven guilty
right
ideally let's not say that the cop was
interrogating you is gonna believe that
in general you're presumed to be
innocent guilty and they say that it's
better than that ten guilty men should
go free that that one innocent should be
sent to to prison or punished what do
you guys think about that
do you think that it is better that
guilty people ten people who committed
crimes violated other legal system
doesn't that one Europeans don't do it
that way every place that is called
napoleonic there is no presumption that
you're guilty
every single place doesn't work that way
everywhere hate stinks doesn't what do
you think yeah well I heard man talk
about he was proven guilty buddy I heard
he wasn't guilty but he was in jail for
like 20 years
yeah he came to my high school to speak
and I think they lose so many rights by
being in prison when they're not
supposed to be that it's a violation
that if you're not if you're innocent in
your proof they think you're guilty
you're losing right a lot yeah if we
look at the individual case of somebody
who is innocent convicted which does
happen then their rights of the violent
sometimes they're a actually able to
bring suits
well let's say we look at the product is
it better than 10 guilty people go free
Tillett area
well you might actually still say yes if
you're really in solitary if you're an
active military absolutely not right ten
guilty people still out there doing bad
things versus one innocent person but if
you're a rule utilitarian maybe it's
more important to respect that one
person's rights so that the system keeps
working otherwise people will have less
faith in the system safety being
railroaded
a lot great with the police effective
operate with the DA's I'm not going to
cooperate that the attorney is society
will loose on legitimacy maybe there's
been maybe maybe there's a good case
from utilitarian perspective for better
left I'm guilty